Hoy quiero hablar en clase de una
noción de teoría de juegos
llamada El dilema del prisionero,
que puede usarse para
caracterizar una estructura
que se propone en el segundo libro
de la República de Platón
y en el capítulo 13 del
Leviatán de Hobbes.
Y el propósito de introducirlos a esta
forma de pensar las preguntas
es exactamente lo que hemos estado
haciendo todo el semestre.
Toma un conjunto tradicional de
cuestiones filosóficas
y preguntar cómo es que la
metodología de otra disciplina
puede arrojar luz sobre estas preguntas
de una forma complementaria.
Recordarán que, al inicio de la
última clase, comencé
con una cita del inicio del segundo
libro de La República de Platón,
cuando Glaucón responde al
desafío de Sócrates
de expresar la naturaleza y los
orígenes de la justicia,
o la naturaleza y los orígenes de
una conducta pro-social,
en términos amplios.
Señalé que la afirmación
que hace Glaucón
toma la forma siguiente.
"Dicen que hacer [justicia]
injusticia es naturaleza buena
y sufrir la injusticia es malo,
pero que lo malo de sufrirla
hasta ahora supera la bondad de hacer
lo que hicieron y sufrieron
y tomaron la injusticia, pero que
carecen del poder de evitar sufrirla,
decidan que es rentable llegar a
un acuerdo con cada uno
para no practicar ni
sufrir la injusticia.
Ilustramos eso con el ejemplo
de los dos pastores,
uno de los cuales roba los
caballos del otro
y obtiene cierto placer de ello,
pero no tanto como el descontento
que recibe el pastor robado
cuando el segundo es
víctima del primero.
Así, ambos terminan en una
situación con menos utilidad
de la que habrían tenido si hubieran
cooperado y se hubieran reunido
y alcanzado alguna forma de pacto.
Glaucón continúa con el pasaje que
también les leí en la clase pasada.
Dice, "La justicia es intermedia
entre lo mejor y lo peor.
Lo mejor es hacer injusticias
sin pagar el castigo.
Lo peor es sufrirla sin poder vengarse.
La justicia es el punto medio
entre estos dos extremos".
Pero no les leí la oración siguiente,
en la que nos concentraremos
en la clase de hoy.
Debido a que Glaucón continúa
señalando esto en su visión,
y como resultará ser, si
ustedes pensaran de justicia
como este tipo de coordinación, o la
visión matemática de alguien...
¿podría pedir a algún TF
que arregle esa puerta,
para que no se azote cada vez
que alguien entra?
Lo que dice es,
"las personas lo valoran no
porque sea bueno, sino
porque son demasiado débiles para
hacer injusticia con impunidad".
Alguien que tiene el poder de dañar a otra
persona sin dañarse a sí mismo,
alguien que tiene el poder de
hacerlo, sin embargo,
no haría un acuerdo con nadie
para no hacer injusticias,
a fin de no sufrirlas.
"Para él, esto sería una locura".
Así, Glaucón nos dio un argumento
que veremos de nuevo en un
minuto en Hobbes,
y que toma la forma siguiente.
Es racional cuando se piensa
que no hay más opción
que cooperar, cooperar y cooperar.
Pero creen que pueden
salirse con la suya
sin que ora persona coopere mientras
actúan en forma no cooperativa,
sería una tontería para
ustedes cooperar.
Sería una locura.
Hobbes dice exactamente lo mismo
en el capítulo 13 del Leviatán.
Recordarán que ahí expresó las dos
primeras leyes de la naturaleza.
Recuerden que las leyes de la naturaleza
son las normas por las que los
seres racionales se rigen,
porque reconocen que en las
normas siguientes
aumenta la probabilidad de preservación
y florecimiento de sus propias vidas.
Así, la primera ley de la
naturaleza es una ley en dos partes.
Dice que hay que buscar la paz si hay
una posibilidad de alcanzarla;
si no, hay que entrar en guerra.
La segunda ley de la
naturaleza, como recordarán,
también expresa un
compromiso condicional
de renunciar a cierto tipo de libertad.
La segunda ley de la naturaleza
dice que hay que estar
dispuesto a ceder sus derechos
en la medida que los demás estén
dispuestos a hacer lo mismo,
y contentarse con la misma
libertad frente a los demás
que ellos tengan frente a uno.
Una vez más, como en la primera
ley de la naturaleza,
renunciar a los derechos es condicional
para que los demás hagan
lo mismo también.
Al igual que Glaucón, Hobbes da
voz a la preocupación
de que esto tal vez no sea factible.
Escribe, "si los otros hombres no
pueden expresar sus derechos
tan bien como él, no hay razón para que
nadie se desvíe de los suyos.
Porque hacer esto sería
exponerse a los depredadores,
a lo que ningún hombre está obligado,
más que disponerse a la paz".
Después de la próxima diapositiva
utilizaremos los marcadores,
de modo que tengan los suyos a la mano.
Sé que algunos de ustedes son
licenciados en economía,
y que varios habrán estudiado
la teoría de juegos.
A ustedes les pido una disculpa
del mismo modo que me disculpo ante
los licenciados en filosofía
por analizar con ustedes el nivel
básico de la República de Platón.
Pero este es un recurso que
todos ustedes necesitan
para comprender la clase, y les
prometo que en pocos minutos
estaremos jugando algunos juegos reales.
Así, el dilema del prisionero
es una forma de representar
en forma gráfica
la estructura contra la que
advirtieron Glaucón y Hobbes.
Y supone representar un par de
opciones por un par de personas,
en una matriz de dos por dos.
Así, por un lado hay una persona, A,
que enfrenta dos
posibilidades en acción.
La primera es que puede
conducirse de forma pacífica,
exponer sus derechos para atacar al
enemigo y, por lo tanto,
renunciar a cierto tipo de libertad.
O bien puede reservarse el
derecho de guerra
y por lo tanto generar en su agresor
una sensación de amenaza.
Su homólogo, B, enfrenta
exactamente el mismo par de
opciones.
Puede conducirse de manera pacífica
y exponer su derecho a atacar,
o bien puede reservar
los placeres de la guerra para los
momentos en que sienta,
de manera preventiva o como represalia,
la necesidad de participar en
una conducta amenazadora.
LO que es importante observar son
los prisioneros... lo siento.
Eso nos da cuatro posibilidades.
A y B pueden conducirse de
manera pacífica.
Es decir, cumplen con la
cláusula inicial
de la primera ley de la
naturaleza de Hobbes.
Saludan de mano el desafío de Glaucón;
ambos se dan entre sí la misma
cantidad de la que Hobbes habla
en la segunda ley de la naturaleza.
O bien, pueden entrar a un
estado de guerra entre sí.
Esto es lo que Glaucón piensa
que surgirá naturalmente
y lo que Hobbes considera que ocurre
en el estado de la naturaleza.
O bien puede ser el caso que A;
la letra de la izquierda se refiere a
A, se conduce pacíficamente;
en tanto que B lo hace de
modo aguerrido.
O bien puede ser el caso que A se
conduzca de modo aguerrido,
en tanto que B lo hace de
manera pacífica.
Lo que es importante es observar
la estructura del Dilema del prisionero,
en el que A tiene el control
sobre qué fila obtiene.
A puede determinar si estamos en
esta fila o en esta otra.
Pero A no tiene control sobre
qué columna se obtiene.
Por contraste, B tiene control sobre
lo que obtiene cada columna,
pero no sobre las filas.
B puede determinar si estamos en
la columna de la izquierda
o de la derecha, pero B no
puede determinar, mediante
su conducta directa, si estamos en la
fila superior o en la inferior.
Ahora bien, quiero
comenzar asegurándome
que todos hayan entendido la
estructura de este problema,
porque como dijo, estoy a punto de
arriesgar dinero de verdad
con ustedes, y quiero asegurarme de
que, cuando tomen la decisión,
lo hagan entendiendo la
estructura del caso.
Permítanme comenzar diciéndoles
cuál es la estructura de preferencia de A
con respecto de los resultados,
y luego pedirles que me digan
con sus marcadores
cuál es la opción racional para A.
Como sabemos de Glaucón, la primera
opción de cualquier persona
es reservarse todos los derechos,
pero hacer que el oponente
ceda los suyos.
Así, la primera opción es que A
se inclina a la guerra,
en tanto que B lo hace a la paz.
La cuarta opción de todos,
como señala Glaucón,
es quedar atrapado después de
entregar las armas,
cuando su enemigo no lo hizo.
Cooperar con el enemigo es no cooperar.
Ésa es la cuarta opción de A.
Pero como Glaucón y Hobbes lo señalan,
entre la opción de paz-paz
y guerra-guerra;
es decir, un estado de la naturaleza
o un estado de la sociedad
en el que hubo una cesión
mutua de derechos,
la segunda opción de todos,
en particular de A,
es estar en un estado de paz y
la tercera opción de A
es un estado de guerra total.
Entonces, la pregunta que
quiero que respondan,
es la opción que haga A es la
fila en la que estaremos.
A puede ponerse en una fila
en la que vaya a tener su
segunda o su cuarta opción.
O bien puede ponerse es un fila
en la que tendrá su primera o
su tercera opción.
Ésa es la decisión que A debe tomar.
Segunda o cuarta opción,
contra primera o tercera.
Eso es todo.
La pregunta, si toman sus
marcadores, es esta.
¿Qué opción, dada esta matriz, es
racional para que la tome A?
¿Es racional para A elegir
de la primera fila,
donde tendrá su segunda o
su cuarta opción,
o lo es elegir de la fila dos,
donde elegirá su primera o
su tercera opción?
Muy bien. Así.
4% de ustedes que quieren
castigar al tipo
que no hizo las cosas que están mal,
cortar al sujeto que apareció
inocentemente en el hospital,
y elegir la opción dominada en una
matriz de dilema del prisionero,
están con nosotros siempre.
Aquellos de ustedes que leen
artículos de psicología
se preguntarán por qué al hacer
análisis estadístico
uno necesita dejar espacio para el
error experimental, pueden ver
una y otra vez la razón de ello en
el entorno de nuestra clase.
Pero 96% de las respuestas trajeron
lo que es implícitamente la estructura
de esta situación, es decir,
que dada la elección entre paz,
donde A obtendrá su segunda
o su cuarta opción;
y guerra, donde tendrá la
primera y la tercera,
lo obvio es que A elija de
la fila inferior.
Así, ya hicimos que A
tomara la decisión.
Lo racional para A es elegir
de la fila inferior.
Por supuesto, la situación para B
es exactamente simétrica.
B elige la columna, de modo
que puede elegir:
la primera opción de B sería
que A fuera pacífico
mientra B es aguerrido;
su cuarta opción sería que A
fuera aguerrido y B pacífico.
La segunda opción de B es paz-paz,
y la tercera opción de B
es guerra-guerra.
Así, para verificar de nuevo y
ver si podemos eliminar
ese 4% residual, intentémoslo de nuevo.
¿Cuál es la elección racional
para B en esta situación?
Si hacen un buen trabajo aquí,
pasaremos al dinero de verdad.
¿Cuál es la opción racional
para B en esta situación,
dado que la paz le da su
segunda o cuarta opción
y la guerra la primera y la tercera?
Veamos cuáles son los
resultados esta vez.
Tres, dos, un segundo y...
[risas]
Profesor Tamar Gendler: Ja, ja, ja.
Muy bien. Excelente. Aquí vamos.
92% de ustedes en la
eternidad en Internet
dieron una respuesta racional
y 8% de ustedes, por siempre,
de manera anónima,
serán conocidos por ponerse
en la situación uno.
Entonces, la estructura del
dilema del prisionero
con respecto de B es también que
la columna que se rechaza
es la de la paz.
Así, tenemos una situación en la
que A determina la fila,
disculpen, donde B determina la columna
y elige la columna de guerra.
A determina la fila y elige
la fila de guerra.
El resultado de esto es que una
situación estable en
los dilemas de este tipo es que todos
terminan con su tercera opción.
Ahora bien, la estructura que acabamos
de describir en el contexto
de la cuestión del contrato social
del estilo Glaucón-Hobbes
es, por supuesto, una estructura
que surge una y otra vez.
Cualquier situación en la que la
persona elija una columna
tiene un arreglo como este,
y la persona que elige la fila
tiene un arreglo como este.
Es decir, cualquier situación en la que
las opciones primera y cuarta
sean asimétricas y a segunda y
tercera sean simétricas,
terminará poniendo a las
personas en una situación
en la que ambas terminarán
con la tercera opción.
Por ejemplo, si ponemos a personas
(somos oficiales de la policía y
ponemos a los criminales
en un dilema; por eso se le llama
el Dilema del prisionero)
en el que damos preferencia a la
confesión unilateral
sobre permanecer en silencio,
resultará que ambos prisioneros se
verán motivados a confesar,
terminando con su tercera
opción en vez de la segunda,
donde ambos guardan silencio.
Si estamos en una carrera de armas
nucleares con otro país,
en el que el desarme mutuo
dejará a ambos países con un
dividendo de paz, eso sin embargo
sería un caso de miedo de que
la otra parte se separe
y el miedo de tal vez terminar
en una de esas celdas,
llevará a ambas partes a
la tercera opción.
Tercera opción.
Si estamos en la situación
que se describió al inicio
de la clase de hoy,
la historia de Hume de dos personas:
ambos se benefician si hacen el esfuerzo
de tratar de desecar en
pantano fuera de su campo,
y ninguno quiere ser el
único en hacerlo,
se obtiene una situación
de no cooperación.
Y ustedes enfrentan
situaciones similares
con cualquier tipo de
escenario competitivo
en el que muchas personas
cooperan para producir
un resultado benéfico para el
grupo en su totalidad,
pero ninguna quiere tomar
una carga indebida.
Así, la vacunación es otro ejemplo
de un dilema del prisionero.
Existe cierto riesgo mínimo
asociado al vacunar a su hijo
o usted mismo, contra una enfermedad.
Hay un riesgo muy bajo de que el
niño se enferme y un riesgo
un poco mayor de que el niño tenga
una enfermedad moderada.
Por otro lado, si nadie
participa en una vacunación,
todos estaríamos mucho peor.
De hecho, se disiparía la
motivación para no vacunar.
Así, de manera más general, el
dilema del prisionero surge
cuando una situación de
cooperación está dominada
por una situación de deserción.
El acertijo de que hablaremos
después de ver unos
ejemplos más es cómo,
si se hace, es posible moverse
de esta a esta celda.
Así, como señalé, los
dilemas del prisionero
surgen en casos asimétricos en los
que una cooperación unilateral
es la opción más costosa,
y donde la deserción unilateral es
la opción más benéfica;
donde la deserción bilateral es
en cierto modo costosa
y la cooperación bilateral es en
cierto modo benéfica.
Ahora bien, ¿cómo
haremos esto en clase?
Esto es lo que se me ocurrió.
Éste es el dilema del aula, y es real.
Es real.
El dinero está aquí, y tengo una lista
de los nombre de los estudiantes
que recibirán dinero por cada
dilema que juguemos.
Ahora mismo jugaremos tres.
Uno de ustedes, que les diré después,
recibirá en realidad una de las
siguientes recompensas.
Si eligen uno, y la mayoría
de la clase elige uno,
recibirán $15.
Si eligen uno, y la mayoría
de la clase elige uno,
recibirán $15.
Aquí hay un billete de 20, y lo
cambiaré para ustedes.
Si eligen dos, y la mayoría
de la clase elige uno,
recibirán $50.
Cincuenta dólares.
Estoy apostando a la teoría de juegos.
Si eligen uno y la mayoría de
la clase elige dos...
quería poner aquí un castigo,
pero no puedo pedirles dinero.
Así que no recibirán nada.
Si eligen dos, y la mayoría
de la clase elige dos,
recibirán $5.
Ahora, para demostrar que
cumplo mi palabra,
Sarah Cox, ¿estás aquí? Sarah Cox.
Sarah Cox, ¿recibiste $5
de mí en marzo...
perdón, el 15 de febrero?
Sí.
Sarah Cox recibió $5.
Observar mis notas me hizo darme cuenta
de que nunca elegí a nadie
para el segundo premio,
y el 22 y 24 de marzo fueron la
semana pasada, de modo que,
¿Tara Abrahan, estás aquí?
¡Guau!
Tara Abraham, recibirás algo, en
realidad recibirás $6,
porque voy a suponer que
estabas en el 97%.
Así, que ven después de la
clase y recibe tu dinero.
Muy bien.
Quiero decirles que soy serio,
y éste es el dilema del aula.
Aquí está.
Si eligen uno, reciben $15 o nada,
dependiendo de lo que haga la
mayoría de sus compañeros.
Si eligen dos,
les juro que soy totalmente serio,
reciben $50 o $5,
dependiendo de lo que haga la
mayoría de sus compañeros.
Hablo en serio.
Comiencen a marcar.
¿Sólo ocho de ustedes?
¿Nadie quiere el dinero?
Voy a iniciar el cronómetro.
No pierdan la oportunidad.
Es dinero de verdad.
Hay una lista de nombres
aquí mismo, de verdad.
Las dos personas que
llamé están aquí.
No están plantadas.
Si no están aquí, alguien más
se llevará el dinero.
Comiencen a marcar.
Tienen 10, 9, 8;
veamos si la teoría de
juegos está de mi lado.
Muy bien, veamos qué obtuvimos.
Muy bien.
La mayoría eligió dos, de
modo que aquí estoy.
Y la persona seleccionada
es Charles Holmes.
Charles Holmes, ¿estás aquí?
Charles Holmes no recibirá
lo que Charles Holmes
pudo haber recibido, que es cero o $5...
muy bien, Charles Holmes
recibe cero dólares,
pero no como resultado de esto.
Sello Lekalakala, ¿estás aquí?
Sello Lekalakala,
¿Sello, respondiste uno o dos?
Respondiste dos.
Sello, después de la clase,
pueden venir a recoger tus $5.
Probemos de nuevo.
Veamos si voy a tener que pagar mis $50.
¿De acuerdo? Aposté a que les
daría $5, y lo hice.
Aviso, ustedes terminaron en el
extremo inferior derecho
del dilema del prisionero.
¿De acuerdo? Probemos de nuevo.
Mismo juego.
Probando de nuevo.
De verdad me arriesgo, ¿no?
Adelante.
Hagan lo que puedan.
Traten de ganar $50.
Dénme sus mejores tiros.
Muy bien. 49 de ustedes.
Arranquemos el cronómetro y veamos
cómo salen los números.
Veamos en nuestro 4, 3, 2, 1 segundos,
en vivo para los públicos de
televisión, 68 y 32.
Muy bien, de modo que una vez más
la mayoría nos puso en dos.
Veamos si hay un vencedor, o qué
recibirá ese vencedor.
$50 o $5.
Lo siento, cero o $50.
Esta vez, la ganadora es Helen Wang.
Helen Wang, ¿vas a recibir cero o $5?
¿Estás aquí, Helen?
Muy bien. Helen, diste...
¿vas a recibir cero dólares o $5?
Recibes $5.
Excelente. Muy bien.
Voy a dar otros $5.
Probemos una vez más.
La teoría de juegos está de mi lado.
Chicos, están en la esquina
inferior derecha.
¿Qué pasa? Este es el dilema del
prisionero para ustedes.
Probemos una vez más.
¿Qué eligieron?
Misma apuesta una vez más.
¿De acuerdo? Tengo todo el
dinero aquí mismo.
De hecho, lo robé del fondo para
el Bar Mitzvah de mi hijo.
Yo no tengo dinero en casa,
pero el tiene mucho.
Muy bien.
Y seré lo bastante afortunado para
devolverle la mayor parte,
de modo que me lo agradecerá.
Muy bien. Veamos cómo van los números.
49 de ustedes están aquí una vez más.
Diez, nueve, ocho, siete, seis,
cinco, cuatro, tres, dos uno.
Veamos si voy a perder algo de dinero.
Cincuenta y cuatro por ciento.
Están cerca.
¡Ajá! Aposté tres veces,
pensando muy muy bien que no
quería apostar la cuarta vez.
Muy bien.
Esta vez, el ganador es Jared Jones.
Jared Jones, ¿estás aquí?
Jared Jones, muy bien.
Jared, ¿recibes cero dólares o $5?
Escogiste dos.
Una vez más $5, y ustedes están en
el extremo inferior derecho
del dilema del prisionero.
Muy bien, chicos; perdieron el
dividendo de paz, ¿correcto?
Habrían estado mucho mejor
si alguien hubiera estado en la
celda de quince-quince.
Y el dividendo de la cooperación,
que no estuvo disponible para
ustedes porque, por supuesto,
esta es una sala muy grande y
están sentados en filas
y no pudieron coludirse y no hubo
mecanismos de cumplimiento.
El dividendo de cooperación no
estuvo disponible para ustedes.
¿Cómo es el dividendo de cooperación?
Funciona así.
Aquí están nuestros dos pastores en
el estado de la naturaleza
y cada uno tiene un jardín.
Pero como es el estado de la naturaleza,
el tipo verde va al jardín del tipo
rojo y se roba un jitomate;
y el tipo rojo, furioso contra el tipo
verde, va al jardín de éste
y lo destroza con su horquilla.
Así, el tipo verde dice,
"no quiero que el tipo rojo
destroce mi jardín con su horquilla".
Voy a poner una barda
alrededor de mi jardín,
y emplea su esfuerzo para ello.
Y el tipo rojo dice,
"no quiero que el tipo rojo se
robe mis jitomates",
y pone una barda
alrededor de su jardín.
Si hubieran sido capaces de
cooperar de alguna manera,
de llegar a algún tipo de arreglo
por el que pudieran mantenerse fuera
del jardín del otro tipo,
en vez de invertir todo ese
esfuerzo en construir las bardas,
habrían invertido su esfuerzo
en lo que Hobbes llama
las características de
una vida cómoda.
Así, el tipo verde pudo haber tenido
un hermoso jardín de flores
que atrajera a los colibríes,
y el tipo rojo pudo
desarrollar un dispositivo
que le permitiera predecir el
movimiento de los planetas.
Cuando no tenemos que emplear energía
en cosas como proteger
nuestra propiedad,
disponemos de energía adicional para
cosas como una vida cómoda.
Y sólo para recordarles
dónde encaja esto
en el contexto de las cosas, ésta es
la explicación de Hobbes de
por qué es racional para nosotros
participar en un contrato social.
Lo que quiero hacer ahora es
presentarles una segunda noción
estrechamente relacionada con el
dilema del prisionero.
Es decir, el Problema de los comunes.
Les daré tres ejemplos de él y
luego jugaremos a otro juego.
También hay dinero de verdad,
así que déjenme decirles que me
quedó mucho de la última ronda.
Este es el Problema de los comunes.
La tragedia de los comunes.
Supongan que viven en una
hermosa área verde
y ustedes y cada uno de sus amigos
pastores tienen una vaca.
Ahora ponen su vaca a pastar en el campo
y todo va muy bien.
Hay un enorme pastizal ahí, y de hecho
ustedes estarían mucho mejor si no
tuvieran una vaca, sino dos.
Así ustedes y cada uno de
sus amigos pastores
se hacen de una segunda vaca
y la ponen a pastar.
Por supuesto, si dos vacas son
buenas, tres serían mucho mejor.
Así, ustedes y cada uno de
sus amigos pastores
se hacen de la vaca adicional, y ahora
tienen tres vacas cada uno.
Tres vacas, cuatro
vacas... ¡fantástico!
Cada uno de ustedes consigue una
cuarta vaca y la pone a pastar.
El resultado, si el marcador funciona,
es que ya no queda más
espacio para pastar.
El campo queda destruido.
Así, los recursos escasos se agotan
a través de la tragedia de los comunes.
Asimismo, ahora estamos en la
revolución industrial.
Ya superamos nuestros días de pastores.
Cada uno de ustedes y sus
amigos industrialistas
crean una planta contaminante,
que aquí está.
Produciendo un poco de contaminación.
Una planta contaminante es buena,
dos plantas son mejores;
de modo que allí van, y ahí
viene la utilidad.
No hay idea de que esto vaya de
forma no cooperativa.
Aquí vamos.
Obtienen su tercera planta a la
velocidad del marcador.
Y la cuarta para cada uno de ustedes.
Como consecuencia, todo el
ambiente se contamina.
Cada uno de ustedes hizo
algo que era racional,
pero el efecto coordinado
de sus acciones
le dio un resultado subóptimo:
un entorno lleno de contaminación.
Observen que podemos pensar
en el problema favorito de
todos en esta clase:
dejarlo todo para después, a la luz
de la tragedia de los comunes.
Supongamos que esta es una
representación de las horas de su
día.
Este es su yo a las 9 de su mañana,
este es su yo al mediodía,
este es su yo a las 6 de la tarde y este
es su yo a las 10 de la noche.
Ahora, su yo de la mañana, el del
mediodía, el de la tarde
y el de la noche quieren jugar una
partida de Angry Birds.
Pero, ¿saben qué?
Si una partida es buena,
dos son mejores.
Dos son buenas, pero tres
son grandiosas.
Tres son grandiosas, cuatro son súper
y, de pronto, pasaron todo el
día jugando Angry Birds.
Así, la estructura de la
tragedia de los comunes
nos confronta no sólo con un
agotamiento de los recursos.
No sólo es la
contaminación del
ambiente
y otros tipos de
degradación que son
resultado
de las acciones que, en lo
individual, no son un problema,
pero al sumarlas, causan
malos resultados.
También es un modo de
pensar una pregunta
que nos hemos hecho varias
veces en el curso.
Que es: ¿cómo estructuramos
nuestras vidas de manera
que nuestros objetivos de corto
plazo sean lo que logramos?
Y cuando digo que no bromeo que el
tropo de la República,
que la persona y la sociedad se
reflejan entre sí de formas
importantes, hay otro lugar del
que no estoy bromeando.
Así, juguemos a nuestra propia
tragedia de los comunes.
Así es como lo haremos.
Muy bien. Este es el trato.
Cada uno de ustedes puede
decidir, en este juego,
si son el nombre que voy a decir, y
tengo más nombres en mi lista;
si son el nombre que llamo, si van a
recibir una recompensa de $1.
En ese caso, opriman uno.
Si van a recibir una recompensa de
$2; en cuyo caso, opriman dos.
O si van a tomar --lo
siento, $10, opriman dos.
O si van a tomar una recompensa,
si se les llama, de $50.
Cincuenta dólares.
Hay un nombre en la lista.
Hay más o menos 100 marcadores;
tienen una posibilidad de 1 en 100
de los $50, si eligen 3.
Pero este es el trato.
Si el total requerido es menor a $150,
recompensaré al estudiante ganador
con la cantidad que solicitó.
Pero si el total solicitado,
y diré que pensé que habría más
marcadores de los que hay,
es un juego más arriesgado para mí,
pero ya veremos.
Si el total requerido es mayor a $150,
el banco de la tragedia de
los comunes quebrará:
demasiadas solicitudes, sin recompensa.
¿De acuerdo? Así está el
juego, 22, 23, 24:
voy a detenerme.
Quiero muchas respuestas en este juego.
Veamos cuántos números entran.
Muy bien, voy a jugar limpio.
Voy a comenzar el conteo ahora mismo.
Diez, nueve, ocho, siete, seis,
cinco, cuatro, tres, dos uno.
¿Sólo hubo 85 respuestas?
Tal vez deba hacer algo de números.
No, no tengo que hacer algo de números.
Quebré.
Ustedes quebraron al banco.
No hay modo, ¿de acuerdo?
Quiero decir, 30 veces 10,
rebasaron por mucho los $150.
Codiciosos, codiciosos, codiciosos.
¿Quién no recibió su dólar?
Kyle Cooper, lo siento.
Pudiste haber recibido algo de
dinero y no conseguiste nada.
Muy bien.
Esta es una interesante
pregunta psicológica,
¿por qué es peor no haber
recibido nada de esa forma
que en la forma en que el resto de
ustedes no recibió nada?
Muy bien.
Lo que ocurre en la tragedia de los
comunes es lo que verán aquí.
Es decir, cada uno de ustedes
hizo lo que era racional de
manera individual;
es decir, 18% de ustedes
buscó todo el dinero.
Pero 38% de ustedes buscó $10.
Sólo 45% de los estudiantes eligió
la opción que fue posible
para que la tomaran todos.
Violaron el imperativo categórico.
Muy bien. Así es la vida.
Pero la pregunta es,
ahora que nos presentamos estas
dos versiones del acertijo,
el dilema del prisionero por un lado
y la tragedia de los
comunes por el otro,
¿qué tipo de estrategias
existen para escapar?
Y en los últimos 10 minutos de
la clase, quiero analizar
a un nivel muy general los tipos de
estrategias disponibles.
Recuerden, el punto es este.
Tres veces de tres posibles,
terminaron en el extremo inferior
derecho del dilema del prisionero.
Terminaron con la tercera opción
en vez de lograr lo que habría sido un
resultado estable, la segunda.
En la tragedia de los comunes, todos,
como resultado de su expresión de
auto-interés racional,
terminaron en una situación en la
que, además, están peor.
¿Qué necesitamos hacer para
escapar de esta situación?
De alguna manera necesitamos
estructurar la situación de decisión
de modo que, o reducimos la utilidad
relativa de la conducta subóptima,
o bien la utilidad relativa de
la conducta óptima.
Es decir, de alguna forma
queremos hacer el caso de que B
no nos está moviendo a la derecha,
y que A no nos está moviendo al fondo.
Es la única forma que tenemos de
salir de esta situación.
Así, hay varios mecanismos a nuestra
disposición para hacer esto.
Podemos presentar algún tipo
de castigo o recompensa
para las celdas
asimétricas de tal manera
que haga el uno menos atractivo, o
el cuatro menos repulsivo.
Así, la llamada de la sirena
de la primera opción
no atrae a B del mismo
modo para desertar,
y el miedo de la cuarta opción no
atrae a A para hacer lo mismo.
El resultado de haber hecho esto
será crear el potencial
para algún tipo de equilibrio estable y
sustentable en la celda preferida.
En nuestro dos-dos, en vez de tres-tes.
¿Qué tipos de mecanismos están
disponibles en este contexto?
En primer lugar, podríamos
ver los castigos
y las recompensas externos.
Una de las cosas que podemos hacer
es simplemente incentivar la
conducta cooperativa.
Podemos hacerlo con
incentivos materiales,
como el aumento de dinero o
bienes: cosas valiosas.
Podemos hacerlo con incentivos sociales.
Podemos tener marcadores de estado
asociados con la cooperación.
Podemos integrar los
costos de reputación.
Cuando juguemos al dilema del prisionero
en las secciones de la próxima semana,
ustedes tendrán una oportunidad de
probar todas estas cosas.
O bien, podemos inducir ciertos
tipos de incentivos personales.
Podemos aumentar sus
libertades o sus privilegios
como resultado de haber cooperado.
Y con respecto de cada uno de
estos tipos de incentivos,
hay contrapartes que son castigos.
Así, habrá castigos materiales
asociados con la no cooperación.
Podemos reducir la cantidad de dinero.
Podemos quitarles algunos de sus bienes.
Puede haber castigos materiales
asociados con la no cooperación.
Ustedes podrían enfrentar una
disminución en el estado
o un aumento en la reputación.
Puede haber castigos materiales
asociados con la no cooperación.
Reducciones en la libertad o
en los privilegios.
Estos son los tipos de
castigos y recompensas
que es posible imponer de tal manera
que cambia la estructura de
incentivos del dilema del prisionero.
Además de que hay distintos tipos
de incentivos y privilegios,
una de las cosas que es importante
reconocer al reflexionar
sobre esta pregunta es que también
puede haber diferentes tipos
de mecanismos de
cumplimiento que
participan.
A la larga, esto nos llevará a
preguntar por qué Hobbes piensa
que se requiere que tenemos el
tipo de fuerza externa
que proporciona el gobierno.
Así, por un lado
podemos tener mecanismos
intrapersonales de cumplimiento.
Podríamos crear dentro de
nosotros mismos ciertos tipos
de actitudes que nos hagan cultivar
la conducta cooperativa.
La consciencia es un caso de
solución intrapersonal
a los problemas de coordinación.
Ustedes internalizan las
normas sociales,
se vuelven parte de su
auto-concepción y, como
resultado,
se conducen en formas pro-sociales.
Podría estar en el contexto de la
tragedia de los comunes.
Podría estar en el contexto del
dilema del prisionero.
Podría estar en el contexto de su
propio cultivo de hábitos
para superar ese dilema del prisionero
intrapersonal y trans-temporal
que todos enfrentamos respecto de las
tentaciones de Angry Birds.
Podría ser algún tipo de esquema
informal, intrapersonal,
implícito o explícito.
Así, por ejemplo, podrían adoptar
una estrategia de cooperación
en el primer episodio del juego
del dilema del prisionero,
y luego seguir al líder de
cualquier cosa que hagan
sus compañeros en el juego, en
episodios subsecuentes del mismo.
Es decir, como lo saben de su lectura,
es llamada la estrategia ojo por ojo.
Y una lectura suplementaria, que
publicaré para ustedes,
dado el tipo de tema de guerra que ha
transcurrido a través del curso,
es un maravilloso escrito
de Robert Axelrod
sobre la evolución de la estrategia
ojo por ojo en las trincheras
durante la Primera Guerra Mundial.
Quedará listo esta tarde.
Así, a veces surgen estrategias
cooperativas informales,
y ya sea de manera implícita o
explícita, las personas participan
en rondas relativamente
estables de cooperación.
Podemos instalar estructuras formales,
interpersonales o institucionales.
Cosas como leyes, y el estado,
donde existe una regulación
de una fuerza externa.
Y por último podemos instalar
varios tipos de controles tecnológicos.
Apagar el Internet
inalámbrico de su
computadora.
Configurar los misiles
durante la Guerra Fría,
de modo que puedan disparar sin
intervención humana
bajo ciertas situaciones.
Y esos dos sirven a la
función del cumplimiento.
Así, las formas de salir del
dilema del prisionero,
del problema de los
comunes, son múltiples.
Y todas usan virtualmente todos los
tipos de consideraciones
que hemos observado en
clase este semestre.
Quiero cerrar haciéndolos ver
qué tanto más claro pensar en
las cosas de esta forma,
espero, les ha permitido entender
la última parte de Hobbes
que leímos para la clase del martes.
Recordarán que les di la primera y
segunda leyes de la naturaleza.
La primera ley de la naturaleza dice,
hagan la paz en la medida de lo posible;
reserven la guerra para cuando sea
estrictamente necesario.
La segunda dijo, cedan sus
derechos exactamente
en la medida que los demás estén
dispuestos a ceder los suyos.
La tercera ley de la
naturaleza, dice Hobbes,
es cumplir con sus alianzas,
pero señala que no
podrán seguir esta ley
que demanda el interés propio
si enfrentan la posibilidad de que
la otra parte no cumpla.
Porque si eso les ocurre,
pasarán de la segunda a
la cuarta opción.
Y nadie quiere terminar ahí.
Así, dice Hobbes, a fin
de tener alianzas
que les permitan prosperar y florecer
y ganar los beneficios de
la cooperación,
debe existir algún tipo de
mecanismo de cumplimiento.
Hobbes sugiere que debe haber
algún tipo de poder coercitivo
que obligue a los hombres por igual
a cumplir con sus pactos,
por el terror de algún
castigo mayor al beneficio
que esperan por violar la alianza.
Es decir, Hobbes expresa las
selecciones que leímos
del capítulo 15 del Leviatán,
una de las estrategias por la que el
análisis matemático del caso,
nos dimos cuenta que sería suficiente
para mover a las personas de la
celda tres-tres a la dos-dos.
La próxima semana veremos dos
tipos de justificaciones
para distintos tipos de
estructura social.
Veremos la llamada de John Rawls a
nuestras nociones de justicia,
y el análisis de Robert Nozick
sobre la noción de libertad.
Y las cuatro personas a
quienes les debo dinero,
acérquense para que les pague.